the pack three missile tested
combat-proven
and deployed
the initial flight test of the pack
three missile against an incoming
tactical ballistic missile re-entry
vehicle target was in March 1999 since
then the pack 3 missile has achieved a
record of unprecedented successes 19
attempts and 17 intercepts
during both developmental and
operational testing the intercepts have
included 12 TBMs
all targets have been representative of
specific threat weapons the TBM targets
have included both full bodied and
separating re-entry vehicle
configurations the flight profiles were
to achieve specific threat trajectories
the cruise missile targets have been 3mq
m107
and one bqm 74 the program incorporates
the department of defense direction of
2000 which enables early fielding of a
capability the incorporation of
performance maturation is accomplished
by block acquisitions this produces a
continuing performance improvement
development process with each production
block these improvements are ongoing
with developmental operational testing
at regular intervals to validate system
performance for example in 2004 a series
of cost reduction initiatives was tested
and these improvements are already being
incorporated into production additional
improvements will be flight tested
during 2005 and beyond program
milestones include first unit equipped
in September 2001 completion of
developmental testing October 2001
operational testing completed at the
Reagan test site in Kwajalein in May
2002 against a reentry vehicle launched
from Wake Island over a thousand
kilometers away production decision and
program acceleration September and
October 2002 deployment to Kuwait for
Operation Iraqi Freedom in late 2002 in
OIF the success rate was 100 percent all
engagements achieved intercept flight
testing resumed in 2004 with three
successful missions
each being a multiple simultaneous
engagement of increasing complexity
operational capability IOC was achieved
in June 2004 one year ahead of schedule
the PAC three missile a significant
upgrade to the Patriot weapon system the
PAC 3 missile in production and
operationally deployed and available for
international sales proven protection
for our combat forces and those of our
allies
the Patriot PAC 3 program is managed by
the US Army and executed by the Army
program executive office missiles in
space and the lower tier air and missile
defense project office in Huntsville
Alabama
Lockheed Martin missiles and fire
control Dallas Texas is the prime
contractor responsible for the pac-3
missiles segments subcontractors on the
pack 3 missile include Boeing Huntsville
Alabama millimeter-wave active radar
seeker
Aerojet corporation Gainesville Virginia
and Camden Arkansas solid rocket motor
and attitude control motors Honeywell
Clearwater Florida
inertial measurement unit and Goodrich
corporation power systems vergennes
Vermont aerodynamic maneuvering system
actuators and electronics